un fax arrive à la rédaction en en tête
un logo qui fait penser à un service de
l'union européenne un numéro de dossier
et la signature du directeur d'un
mystérieux pôle administratif rgp des on
nous invite à nous mettre en conformité
avec la nouvelle loi pour éviter une
forte amende pour en savoir plus nous
décidons d'appeler le numéro en nous
faisant passer pour une auto école de 14
salariés alors que notre école vous êtes
une auto école
vous avez vous avez ces de france 3
bourgogne et la franche-comté mais ça
il s'agit en fait d'une société privée
qui nous propose ce service est donc
rapidement on va parler argent et vous
avez une obligation juridique de
garantir que le traitement des données
ont formé sécurisé c'est-à-dire vous
avez fait est ce que votre registre qui
est conforme avantage c'est en passant
par non vous avez un tarif forfaitaire
que si vous prenez un cabinet d
expertise pour vous mettre en conformité
ou un cabinet d'avocats d'accord
certains chiens afin là le coût est bien
plus onéreux d'accord ça dépasse avec
les deux trois mille euros un facile
alors que la 14 salariés
vous êtes à 980 euros et donc ça ça
serait de tout de suite maintenant tout
de suite maintenant d'accord
renseignements pris aucune certification
expertise n'est exigée par la nouvelle
loi sur la protection des données
on nous aurait donc menti fax en main
nous allons voir les services de l'état
pour connaître leur a dit oui bonjour on
a un document sur lequel on a vite et
d'avoir votre avis tout le monde
oui et bien ce type de documents et des
japonais nokia tu vises un tu parce que
nous avons déjà eu des plaintes pour
retenir ce type de pratique dans le
langage courant oui ça va être une
arnaque ainsi vous voulez
bon maintenant pour nous sur le plan
juridique on le qualifie rhin en fait de
pratiques commerciales trompeuses
avant nous dans ces mêmes locaux la
confédération de l'artisanat des petites
entreprises du bâtiment était déjà venu
sonner la nerthe mais malheureusement
c'est pas la première fois qu'on a ce
type de ce type d' alerte à chaque fois
qu'il ya une nouvelle loi qui est qui
sort qui est prêt qui prévoit une
nouveauté il ya toujours des entreprises
mal intentionnés qui profitent de ce
créneau et pour les professionnels mieux
vaut être vigilant car en cas de
démarchage à distance contrairement aux
particuliers il n'y a pas de droit de
rétractation
ouf à france 3 on n'a pas contracté